welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for the spatial
genomics scientific track
my name is kip berman and i am the
product manager for geomix rna assays on
the digital spatial profiler
the spatial genomics track has three
unique presentations given by the
following speakers
professor moowong yang from the national
yangming university in taiwan
dr karen pelka from the broad institute
in cambridge massachusetts
and dr sergius zadrakian and laura
perrin
from the children's hospital of los
angeles
our first presentation is titled the
spatial evolution
of epithelial mesenchymal program of
head and neck cancer
it is my pleasure to introduce professor
yang md phd a urology researcher and
assistant professor
at national yangming university taipei
taiwan
if any questions arise during the
presentations
we encourage you to submit them in a q a
box
we will respond back to your questions
via email
please join me in welcoming professor
yang
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
thank you for the introduction my name
is muham
and i will start my today's presentation
about the spatial evolution of the emt
program
in head and neck cancer
so the emt program is um is an
important process for the cancer
metastasis
as you as we know the epithelial cancer
cell should transit into
the partial completely mesenchymal form
to complete the metastasis and the
invasive cancer cells should be
in the so-called the mesenchymal-like
cancer-cell state
and after reaching the methodology they
decide the reverse process
they call met occurs and the
mesenchymal cancer cell lost their
mesenchymal phenotype and then reverse
back to epithelial
phenotype
so the concept of the binary em status
and has been noted for the decades
and the epithelial tumor should
transit into the mesenchymal ones and
then reach the metastatic size
and then reverse back to epithelial
tumor
however there is a question that whether
the binary em status
is sufficient to explain the complicated
mentality process
so therefore the emerging concept about
the em plasticity
that means they should a transistor
or a hybrid intermediate state between
the epithelia and the mesenchymal cell
because the completely transition
is not able to fully explain the
complicated
and metastatic process
so the recent publication and suggests
the intermediate state between the
epithelial and the mesenchymal phenotype
and harbor the higher plasticity and
also have a higher standard
probability and also have the
ability to metastasize so the advantage
of the hybrid state
is important and also highlight
in this process of metastasis
so our recent paper and we show that
even we use the emt canonical emd factor
snail to induce the emt but the partial
emt program was noted in head and neck
cancer
and the collective migration
was shown in the cancer cell expression
of the emt factor snail
and the cloud 11 which is the hearing
protein
is induced by the emd factor snail to
promote
the so-called collective migration
and for the clinical sample it had the
neck cancer
you can see when the primary tumor
expressed
now and we can see a higher incidence
of the patient we have the so-called
cluster in ctc
the clustering circulating human cell
that means
the cancer cell not disseminated as a
single cell
but they move together as a clustering
so this one has been this study has been
published in
nature cell biology in last year
so our major question is because the
binary em status is not able to fully
explain
the complicated metastatic process so
whether
the spatial evolution of the em program
that means
is a is a continuous spectrum
and the net should be an spatial
evolution
and from the primary tumor to the
invasive from
to the circulating tumor cell to the
messeng to the metastatic side
so we try to answer this question
by two different strategies the first we
try to use the direct ion sequencing
and the second strategy is to use the
dsp for spatial transcriptomics
analysis so we would
we will show our data about the direct
ionic sequencing
so for sequencing the different part of
the tumor
and we collect 20 heteronic cancer
patient pair
sample including primary tumor and
the metastatic lymph node for the
primary tumor
we separate into the invasive rung
which is the three millimeter from the
stroma tumor border
and we also collect the inner site so
for each patient
we will have the primary tumor and the
metastatic tumor
and the primary tumor include the
invasive from
and the inner tumor side and therefore
we can
we can observe these spatial evolution
from the inner side to the invasive
front and to the metastasis side
so then we use the emt score to
calculate whether
the primary tumor and through the
metastatic human
has a spectrum shift of the en program
and as we can see the invasive front has
an
elevated em score but this seems to have
a two
population and one has a higher emd
score
and the other remain in the epithelium
phenotype
and all the metastatic tumors have a
higher
emt score than the primary one
indicating that
the emt may not be completely converted
back to the epithelium status in the
metastatic side
so you it will be very interesting to
study
the spatial transcriptomic drift during
the metastatic process
so then we use the 826
82 emt gene signature from the recent
publication
in head and neck cancer to analyze our
ionic data
and we can see four clusters the first
step
of emt is to up regulate
further upper regulate the epithelium
and the both mesenchymal marker
and then the epithelial marker decreased
and the continuous elevation of
mesenchymal mark was seen
in the head and neck cancer samples
and this data is
consistent with the data
published in last year and the first
step of emt is the epithelial phenotype
and then the partial emt the predominant
epithelial phenotype the partial emt
predominant mesenchymal phenotype
and then completely convert to the
mesenchymal phenotype
we can clearly separate the head and
neck cancer into the fore group
suggesting that the partial emt
and the concentration of the e and n
marker
indeed exist in head and neck has a
sample
so the second strategy to elucidate
the spatial transcriptomics is to use a
dsp
which is a perfect method for
analyzing any different transcriptomic
in the same tumor
so this is a summary of dsp i think
and all the audience are very
familiar with the this tool
so our strategy is to select a different
roi
the invasive from the inner cyber tumor
and we select the invasive rung by using
both the morphology
and also use the fluorescent marker and
we select the roi in the border
of the straw massager and the epithelial
cell
and for the inner side we select the
tumors
and far away from the the invasive from
and we also have the the
metastatic tumor so we selected the
fluorescent marker include a t cell
marker cd3
and the macrophage marker cd68
and the epithelial marker pen ck for
indicating the different cell population
in the same roi so this is a preliminary
result of the
the dsp the fluorescent image and we can
see
the normal tissue the inner tumor the
outer tumor you can see
the partial emt phenotype is very
obvious
and this is a metastatic tumor
and then we use the cancer transcript
krypton and
atlus the cta profiling to analyze
the result from different roi so
now we have the outer tumor how i have
17
the inner tumor we have ri 13
and we have 30 metastatic side tumor
and then we analyze and then an
interesting result is shown
that distinct genes virgin profile
in a different inner out outer or
metastatic site tumor
indicating the spatial transcriptomics
indeed exist in head and neck cancer
so then we try to analyze the spatial
evolution
for this case we can see the inner tumor
the outer tumor
the metastatic tumor harbor the distance
that the the distinct the transcript
atomics
and the outer tumor share the
intermediate state
between the inner and the metatarsal
tumor as we can see
this is a metastatic tumor this is
an e inner tumor here
and this is the outer tumor altitude
mature
both the transcriptone from the inner
tumor
and the outer tumor and and then
metastatic tumor
and this is a pca for
visualize visualization of the
spatial transcriptomic trees in
in the head and neck has a sample and
in another case they're very similar
transcription
make drift and you can see this is a
metastatic tumor
and then this is the inner tumor for the
outer
tumor is also like a transient
long and more similar to the metastatic
tumor
so i think the major gap for the
metastasis
is from the inner to the outer and then
the transcriptome
is a relatively similar between outer
and the metastatic site
and then this is a pca for visualization
so then we use the cta profiling and
then we found
in the inner tumor they express some
important molecule and for the outer
tumor we can see
clearly there are some stroma type
molecules such as the fibronectin
and the collagen and also express some
here a
and interestingly the ctn and b1
and continuous elevativated doing
the movement from the inner side to the
outer side and you can see later
to the metastatic side so this is
the volcano plot to compare the outer
tumor to the metastatic one
and you can see for the metastatic side
you can see some
some stromal angiogenesis related
the marker then the outer tumor
and the major reason is a mesenchymal
trauma part
so we can briefly summarize here
the inner tumor may express the
epithelial mark
and the outer tumor has a mesenchymal
stroma marker and the metastatic tumor
which is relatively similar to the outer
tumor express
both the the mesenchymal marker and also
the angiogenesis marker
and some molecule continuous elevated
during
the step of metastasis and one of the
best example is the
ctmb1
and then if we look at
some markers such as the fibronectin
which is a major mesenchymal marker
and you can see the outer tumor
significantly
significantly increase the expression
of the fibronectin and if we
use this so-called emt marker and
to see whether there is is there any
different
picture between the inner tumor and the
other tumor you can see a significant
difference
between the inner human and outer tumor
and also for the metastatic tumor
so the most consistent
molecule continues elevated during
the process of the inner side move to
the outer side
ctl and b1 and you can see in the inner
side
and then the ct and b1 elevated to the
outer side
and further increased to the metastatic
side
so then we use the another sample
which have just described in our
first section is that we use the anger
sick for the
inner side tumor and the invasive rung
and we can also see the beta-carotene
continuously elevated during the process
of the so-called out inner to outer
alter to metastasis and very consistent
to the data from the dsp
so i would like to mention another
interesting findings that
so even we use the so-called emt
signature the emt signature is different
between the inner tumor metastatic tumor
and outer tumor that means the emt
is not only the same status
in the inner tumor the emt may be in the
start to drive status in the outer tumor
may be more like in the hybrid status
and the mesenchymal tumor
may be related with more mesenchymal
status and the
also mix some angiogenic factor so
we even we use the so-called mesenchymal
marker
they are still different and this is
case one and you can see all these
emt markers that the
expression signature are distinct
between the inner tumor
invasive from and the metastatic tumor
and also the scent you can see
in the case two in the case three
and we also have some interest in
finding that
and in our previous knowledge the emt
factor is the driver for emt
but interestingly you can see the emt
factor
continuously decreased during the
process
of inner to outer to metastatic movement
that means the emt factor indeed is the
so-called driver
for this process so it's highly
expressed in the inner side
and reducing further reducing the outer
side
and the metastatic side in contrast the
mesenchymal marker such as the
fibronectin
and the cd44 steadily increased
and during the metastatic process from
the inner side
increased to the outer side and then to
the metastatic side
the cd44 are the same as fibronectin
so this phenomenon and
the universally seen in all the sample
studies studying and analyzed by dsp
and the similar pattern also seen
in the analytic analyzed
samples so the interesting finding is
that if
we look at the morphology and we can see
the outer tumor
some outer tumor has a so-called
mesenchymal phenotype
and then you can see the cell has a
mesenchymal
like cell and the sum of the sample
has an epithelial final time they are
quite different
so and the phenotypes quite
correlate with the level of snail
so in the first case and you can see
the level of snail significantly reduced
as we just mentioned snare is a emd
driver
in the inner side and in the outer side
and then reduced
and you can see a relative mesenchymal
phenotype so this
concept may be contradictory to our
knowledge that the snail expression can
drive the mexican phenotype
but for the continuous em spectrum
and we suggest the
emt factor is the initiator of this
process
and the when the cell convert to more
mesenchymal status
the ent factor will reduce before the
the the rising of the mesenchymal marker
so if the outer tumor still is very
snare
they will look like an epithelial
phenotype
so another part is we
look at the stroma and we use a pencil
connective
roi and i think it's also the advantages
part of the dsp analysis
and we use the cta to analyze this
trauma and then the primary side and the
metastatic side
also show distinct profile
and we especially focus
on the milo signature again
and both of my low signature but the
primary tumor
and the metastatic tumor is expressed
quite different myeloid signature
and the myeloid signature in primary
tumor
and the mix of the activated or or
but for the metastatic side is
relatively
likely alternatively activated or the
immunosuppressive macrophage
so this is also confirmed by
several different samples so
this interesting finding we also
validate
in our rna-seq samples so we collect
the sample for rna-seq as we just
mentioned in the first section
and then we use the cyber salt to
analyze the major in infiltrated
immune cell and propose infiltrated
immune cell
in the analyzed data and very
interestingly
we also found a similar pattern in the
primary tumor
it's a relative so-called mixed type of
macrophage but in the maintenance tumor
is an immunosuppressive macrophage
or you can call it the mental macrophage
predominantly in the
metastatic tumor which is quite
consistent
with the data in dsp
i will have a short conclusion about my
desktop
today's talk first we demonstrate the
spatial transcriptomic drift of the
epithelial mesenchymal program
in head and neck cancer by both rna-seq
and
dsp so the consistent data show
the inner side to outer side to
metastasis side
and it's a gradually drift rather than
the
binary status of en and the
major gap between this process
is the inner side to the outer side
because the outer side
is relatively shared some transcriptomic
signature
with the metastatic side the second
finding is that
the ctn and b1 is a consistent
upregulated gene throughout the process
of metastasis
from the inner side to the outer side to
the metastatic side
and both in the dsp and on sick data
and another is the emt factor
is higher in the inner side but reduced
during the process of metastasis so this
gives us a very exciting insight that
the emt transcription effect must
proceed before the process
of the transcriptomic drift as the
driver
and then change the gene expression
program
and then they should disappear
and for the complete conversion of
mesenchymal final time another inside
step
and as we know the metastatic tumor
the behavior is totally different from
the primary tumor
so the previous concept about the met
the reverse back to epithelial type that
should be re-evaluated
according to the dsp data
and another interesting data is that
that this thing the milo pattern
signature is noted between the primary
and the metastatic tumor
so the both are tumor and both have the
infiltrated myeloid or
macrophage but their pattern are
distinct
that private human and major decomposers
mix pattern and the metastatic tumor the
immunosuppressive
signature is predominant so we use the
dsp
by taking the advantage of the the
dependency connective stroma roi to
understand this
and we also use the cypress salt
profiling of the ionic data to very
satisfying
i thank for my colleagues for helping
me to complete this interesting program
thank you for your attention
that was a wonderful presentation uh
thank you so much we just
have a couple questions here we'd like
to ask you
um so so for the first one um
can you speak a little bit more about
your rri strategy
um whether you use polygons or geometric
and
you know how you took advantage of the
morphology of the tissue
um and the fluorescent markers that you
used
thank you so for the ri selection
strategy
we select the roi together with the
pathologist because the tissue sometimes
folded on the slide so we
we select our act together with the
pathologist
to confirm this is a so-called inner
side
i think the outer side selection should
be more important because
we should use both the morphology
as well as the immunofluorescent
marker such as we we should
select the the h the border of the
and ck-positive and the stroma
border as the outer and the inner we
should confirm is the pathologist and
there is
no stroma and around the so-called inner
tumor
for the metastatic tumor and then we
evenly distributed roi throughout the
metastatic tumor so we did not
separate the so-called inner metastatic
outer metastatic
yes well that makes sense it's wonderful
uh
so then what is your next steps for this
research
so the next research is we will try to
validate
the finding the major finding of this
study is that
the transcriptome drift from the inner
side to the outer side
and the driver is starting the inner
side and disappear in the outer side
so we need to do two things is first to
validate in
more and more human samples and
therefore we try to increase the number
of dsp and also to try to validate this
result
the second is we we have some
candidate and key transfusion factor and
we will try to use a chipset or other
strategy to to
demonstrate the spatial transcriptomics
are driven by several key transcription
factors
and the binding of the target gene
uh gradually drift from the inner side
to the outer side
i think is my next part of
research plan that sounds
very exciting thanks again for uh the
really interesting uh work and
the presentation
thank you very much would like to
introduce our next presenter dr karen
pelka from the broad institute dr
pelka's presentation is titled
cellular elements and spatially
organized immune hubs in colorectal
cancer
please join me in welcoming dr pelcom i
will now
hand the presentation over to her
thank you very much kid for the very
kind introduction it's my great pleasure
to be here and to
to talk to you today
the overall goal of our project is to
understand and improve immunotherapy of
colorectal cancer
now to reach this goal we had to solve
one main question
that i think is of great interest to
many of us how can we gain
insights into complex human tissues
now what i would like to do today is to
share with you our approach to this
problem
and show you what we did to reveal
immune hubs in human colorectal cancer
in the first part i will show you how we
use single cell rna sequencing to
predict multicellular interaction
networks
you probably all know that single cell
rna sequencing is a great method
to resolve the cellular composition of
tissues
and to identify cellular elements what i
think hasn't been appreciated as much
as that you can also use just rich data
set to
essentially discover in a relatively
unbiased way
transcriptional programs now looking at
our data set through the lens of gene
programs was really key for us to
discover these interaction networks
because we essentially could look at
them as program program interactions
in the second part i will then show you
how we use imaging technologies to
validate
our predictions and also to understand
our interaction networks in the context
of the tissue
now why are we so interested in the
immunology of colorectal cancer
well colorectal cancer exists in two
immunological distant
distinct types microstable and microsoft
instable tumors
the microsoft instable tumors are
present only in about 15 percent of the
patients
but these tumors are highly infiltrated
with immune cells and have a roughly 50
response rate to immunotherapy
unfortunately the vast majority of
patients presents with mss tumors and
those tumors have much less immune cells
and are essentially unresponsive now
to understand a little bit better what
the immunology in these tumors looks
like
we collected a cohort of 34 msi patients
and 28 mss patients and we applied
single cell rna sequencing
so here you can see a teasing of our
data set across both the
mss and the msi collective specimens and
the adjacent normal colon tissue we
collected about 400 000 cells
and then we performed a hierarchical
clustering approach
so on the highest level of clustering
these cells essentially group by cell
lineages
and then we took each of these lineages
and subclustered
in a total of 87 clusters across all
non-malignant cells
in correct cancer the malignant cells
are epithelial cells
um so we're zooming into the epithelial
cells now because
the malignant cells actually as you can
see here group by patient
the normal epithelial cells that are
shown in green
are nicely mixed between different
patients as did all the other cells in
the data set
but the malignant cells as you can see
show all these patient-specific
islands consistent with the clonal
nature of the malignant cells
now we were interested if these
patient-specific signatures are actually
characteristic for the individual tumors
um and they were since when we applied
the nanostring geomics dsp
technology to sample multiple different
regions of these tumors
multiple different malignant regions we
could recapitulate
the singles rna sequencing signatures
that we
identified before so let's move to the
gene programs
in order to discover gene programs we
applied an approach that is called
non-negative matrix factorization
this is essentially a dimensionality
reduction method
that is really good in extracting
interpretable features from
from complex data sets so in the case of
the picture of the space here
the features for example can be the part
of the eyebrow or
or the part of the nose and then
what you also get is a matrix that
essentially tells you the activity
how much of this feature is used so in
this case it would be how dark the pixel
is
in the case of our transcriptional data
the gene the features are the gene
programs
and the activities are how much of this
program is used by any given cell
so we applied this approach both to the
different cell types and to the
malignant cells from each patient and
ended up with 221 nmf based gene
programs
now looking through these gene programs
we were really satisfied to see
a lot of familiar programs so for
example in the mile itself the program
seven
um turned out to be a pdc program and
you can see how the activity is really
high just in one little part of this big
global cheese name
or the first program of the stroma cells
is a smooth muscle cell program
now while these programs were very
patient very cell type specific
we also identified programs that were
actually active in multiple cell types
so for example an interferon stimulated
gene program
in the male itself or a proliferation
program
in the malignant cells we identified
programs that essentially were only
active and in single patients like this
program here in patient one
but what was really good for us we also
identified
a lot of programs that actually were
shared across
multiple patients so the example that
i'm showing you here is an inflammation
program
so essentially we had a tool set with
which we could
look through our data set now 21
programs sounds like a lot but luckily
we can organize them
um into into similar programs um so
this is shown here um for example
we find proliferation programs in all
the different cell types or or
and many of them we find these
interference stimulated gene programs
and they're highly similar and can
group can be grouped together
now how can we how can we get from these
teen programs to
interaction networks so here we
leveraged the fact that we
had a quite sizable cohort and so we
were able to look
for the core presence of programs across
our
patient specimens and we ended up
actually doing that separately for msi
and mss tumors because
indeed these two tumor types are quite
distinct from each other
so on the right you can see one of these
co-occurrence matrices
um between t cells myla cell and
malignant cell programs in
microsoft instable tumors and
what is shown here is all the rows are
programs and the column cell programs
and whenever
it's red it means that these programs
co-occur together and blue means that
they're anti-correlated
so for the rest of the talk i will zoom
into one of these interaction hubs
and this is what we think is the
anti-tumor immunity hub in
msi tumors so what's underlying these
co-occurrences are essentially pairwise
correlations
and some of them are shown on on the
left of the slide
and some of the key programs that
co-occur
here are two t-cell programs program 18
and program 6
a myelin program program 21 and a
malignant program program 19.
now what are these programs so program
18 and 6
and the t cells actually map to
activated t cell clusters
i'm consistent with that the clusters
that have the highest activities for
these programs are highly enriched in
the msi tumors
also if we look just on on at on the t
cell level
and compare the different patients you
can see that the activities of these
programs indeed
tend to be much higher in the most items
you can also see that there's quite a
spread though also there are some msi
patients that actually do not have
much of these highly activated t-cell
programs
and what are the mallet and the
molecular programs well they actually
group
together with these isg programs
so based on this currents and the
receptors and ligands that are present
in these programs
we then came up with the following
prediction so
program six and the t cells contains
enzo from gamma the antifrom gamma
can act on the malignant and the
maryland cells and upregulate
these interference stimulated genes part
of these isgs
are the cxci3 ligands the axia 10 and 11
and the mallet cells also cxen9
and these can act on cx3 which is
expressed by the t
cells and potentially cause the
accumulation of
of the t cells in in the tumor
so we wanted to test this prediction and
turn to to the imaging the first
question
here was where are these t cells and
this is now
a picture of one of these um
cancer specimens and what we stained
here is a cxcf13
and cd3 for t cells the immunologist
among you
probably know cxef13 as a chemokine that
is really important in the generation of
lymphoid structures
and there it's thought to be expressed
by follicular dendritic cells and
important for the recruitment of b
cells now consistently with that we do
see a lot of
cxcf butane signal in this lymphatic
structure that is
right below the tumor and you can see
that indeed it maps to the b cell zone
but you can also see that here indeed
it's not expressed
um but mostly not expressed in the t
cells
instead the cxo3 and positive t cells
actually are
in the tumor itself so they're really in
the tumor bad and they form these little
accumulations
um i should also mention the 60 of 13 t
cells
have only been really recognized um
quite recently
because they do not exist like that in
mouse but in human now they really
emerge to be the the tumor reactive t
cells now
to assess whether this
cell circuit is really happening and the
tissue as well and whether the core
occurrence translates into
into a spatial relationship between
these programs
um we applied to the nanostring geomix
dsp
technology and leveraged the fact that
you can also segment
regions of interest so like this we were
able to look at the malignant cells in
the pancake positive region
and look for these icg signatures at the
same time we were able to look at cfcf13
signal and the stroma cell region in the
panzerkin negative region
and because these regions are paired we
were able
to really understand that indeed the
cx13 signal and the ice cheese signal
were correlated with each other
suggesting that indeed they were
close together in the tissue encouraged
by these results we then designed a
rna-ish if panel to look more
specifically at the cxa 10 11 which we
had predicted to be important for the
recruitment of these t
cells and you can see here that
the cx 10 11 indeed mapped to the
malignant cells
and it occurred in these little focal
clusters
right at the malignant cell stroma cell
interface
moreover these are 10 11 positive
malignant cells
really associated with the interphone
gamma and
cx13 positive t cells
and this is showing you a higher
magnification
now since we actually did whole slide
scans of a number of these patients we
were also able to quantify that
um and you can see that indeed the
distance between 6 year
10 11 positive malignant cells and these
specific t cells
were significantly shorter than the 6a
1011 negative malignant cells
now i've talked about the positive
effect of this feedback
of this feedback loop and namely the
accumulation of the tumor reactive t
cells in the tumor
but unfortunately there's also an
inhibitor part to this interaction
part of this ist program are inhibitory
molecules such as pdl1 and ido1
so we wanted to look at that a little
bit closer
and leverage the fact that in addition
to the rna assay
we also ran a multiplex protein assay on
our tissue specimens
so we were able to call isg high versus
low
regions in the malignant cells and then
look at the protein expression
on these consecutive slides and across
multiple patients indeed
the ict high regions were
had significantly higher higher levels
of pdl1 and ido1
and in this case also pl2
there was one patient that actually
stood out already from the single cell
rna sequencing data
this is patient 110 so we wanted to have
a closer look at this patient this
patient already
in the single cell data set had
screamingly high iq1 levels
and um as you can see on the right also
on rna and protein level
and c2 with the geomex tsp approach
we could see really high levels of idea
one in this patient compared to the
other patients
so we wanted to know where exactly these
idea one high
high regions map in the tissue and it
turned
out that this tumor actually had um
different zones to it
if you want so so there was a low grade
part of the tumor and in this part
the t cell entrotates were low and the
ido1 levels were low
but then there was a high grade region
um that was heavily infiltrated by
t-cells and where the ideo1 levels were
really high
also um this patient had a lymph node
metastasis and we were able to sample
that as well
with this spatial technology and you can
see that also here the idea one program
was really high
so this suggests that while this
interaction network
might be beneficial to recruit
anti-tumor t cells
it might also eventually lead to the
immune evasion of the tumor
and to an immune suppressive environment
and potentially the progression of the
tumor
so with this i would like to end what
i've shown you today is that we can use
singles rna sequencing to predict
multicellular interaction networks
um we did that by looking at our data
set through the lens of
team programs which allowed us to look
for the co-occurrence of programs
and thereby discovered these interaction
networks and then
we took these interaction networks and
localized them in the
tissues so i showed that to you
one example of the potato antitumor
immunity hub
this was really important because one it
tells us where exactly in the tissue
this is happening
and also it allows us to now access
samples that are actually are not
accessible to us
um as fresh specimens for the singles
rna sequencing
and with this i would like to thank
everyone involved this is a
huge collaborative team effort that i'm
actually leading together
with jonathan jonathan chen a
pathologist and martin hoffrey
my computational partner i would
like to thank my mentors neeha koen and
avi fregev
as well as my wonderful collaborators at
mgh the brigham women's hospital
the abergrant center i would like to
thank our funding sources from nih
my fellowship from the german research
foundation as well as funds
from stand-up to cancer and project
night and all patients that were
willing to donate tissue to our project
thank you very much
thank you dr pelka that was a wonderful
presentation
um we actually just have some questions
here we we'd like to ask you and get
further thoughts on
um so the first one here is how do the
nmf based gene programs compare or
relate to
the clusters that you found
yes so essentially you can think about
the clusters as combination of gene
programs
same for the individual cells so to give
an example
your cluster might be a proliferating
regulatory t-cell cluster
now in this case the programs would be a
proliferation program
and a t-rec program and in our case
we actually used this nmf based approach
as the underlying dimensionality
reduction method for all of our analysis
so also the clusters are based on on
these nmf chain programs
excellent um so how did you select your
s
your specimens for the staining
validations
yes that's also a really good question
so in our case right we built this cord
from scratch so we actually
collected some surgical specimens from
patients at mdh
and the brigham vince hospital um so
we had access to the pathology archives
from from both of these hospitals and so
we
were able to actually pull the pathology
blocks from exactly the patients that we
have profiled and i think
that's very powerful because then you
already know what the transcriptional
programs in this specific patient are
and you can validate that in exactly the
magic specimen
and in addition you can um like in the
idea one patient case right
we were able to so we only profiled the
primary tumor by single cell
but then we were able to look at lymph
node metastasis also by
using pathology specimens yeah
um then what was your strategy then when
you have those samples what was your
strategy for placing your region's
bishop
regions of interest on the tissue yeah
um so there it depended a little bit on
on the exact
um experiment in the experiment where we
looked for the correlations
we actually essentially sampled the
complete slide because we wanted to have
as many
data points as possible so those were
literally 96 um
data points per per specimen um but for
other applications so for example when
we wanted to validate that these
malignant signatures are really
characteristic for the individual
patients
as i showed at the start we made sure
that we sampled different regions so for
example we sampled regions from the
invasive margin we sampled
regions that are close to the colonic
lumen
and we also sampled some special regions
um so for example
one tumor had a vascular invasion um so
we made sure to also
look at those special regions
did you see a lot of heterogeneity
between or within the patients
yes so we did see a lot of hedogenetic
both
between the patients and within the
patients um
but what i think our data set can do is
um
i think it can help to kind of organize
the cdo genetia
a little bit better and what i mean by
that
um so if you look at the different
regions they are different
um but then if you look at it and the
land of these programs and the dents of
these interaction hubs
you start to realize that it's way an
overlay of these different immune hubs
on top of each other so for example this
antitumor immunity hub that i showed
um you could see that it was definitely
not um homogeneously
present in the specimens right it was
these really focal areas
that light it up so if you sample and
you hit one of those then your signal is
very different than if you
do not hit one of those right but
understanding um
which programs go together and and and
what immunological process they're
involved i think really helps to
understand
why there's heterogeneity and and what
it actually means
yeah that's really important and i guess
that leads to my last question
um do you think that the the anti-tumor
hub that you found
uh will be able to predict uh
immunotherapy response
yeah that's a question that we always
get asked
that's a tricky one uh because
unfortunately the answer is not a simple
yes
um but i think um it's it's really
important to understand this and i
i'll try to explain what i mean so one
um there recently has been a
study this year actually from a group in
the netherlands that um
gave immunotherapy prior to uh resecting
the specimens as neo-adjuvant therapy
and so what they could see is that
post-treatment
indeed ice-t signatures went up so
meaning that
um these isgs indeed go up when you
when you boost the immune response
however that happened in both
responders and non-responders so there
are definitely other features that
then um determine whether at the end you
respond or not
now the reason why i think this is still
really really important to know is
if you think about a patient that does
not have any of these immune hubs
so no 6 year 1011 signal no iced teas
um no 16 t cells the treatment for a
patient like this
you can imagine has to be very different
than for a patient like for example this
idea one patient right
where there was a lot of anti-tumor
activity but where
these immune pressure features are
already really high
so i think it helps you to decide what
the right treatment for
each individual patient should be
yeah based on the biology that you're
seeing yeah
yeah in those hubs but this has been a
wonderful and very
insightful presentation and discussion
um thank you dr belka we really
appreciate it
thank you very much it was my pleasure
it's now time for the final presentation
of the spatial genomics track
this project um was awarded to
researchers at the
children's hospital of los angeles
through the whole transcriptome atlas
grant
um this will be presented by our winners
dr sergius sedrakian and lauren paren
the title of their presentation is the
mechanisms of alport syndrome
pathogenesis
please welcome dr sedrakian and perrin
and now i'll hand this over presentation
to
both of them
thank you so much for the invitation and
um we're going to talk today about um
this project
and the um transcriptomics especially
resolve analysis that we have done
on the structures of the nephrons in a
healthy and in chronic kidney diseases
and particularly also in albert syndrome
just a little bit of background about
chronic kidney disease it affects
more than 47 millions of people in the
united states
and the number is rapidly increasing
over the years
there are different stages of
chronic kidney disease but when the
patient
reaches stage number five where the
kidney function is below 15
at that point the patients using the
rent exchange rental disease and you
need that cardiologist or
transplantation
um kidney disease is not only important
for clinical relevance but
also it really affects our economic
system and health
our health system and indeed in 2019
uh medicare budget for chronic kidney
disease
was around 114 billion dollars
almost 23 percent of the entire
health expenses uh kidney disease
um there are a lot of different type of
cardio disease around
from the most common one like
nephropathy or genetic disease like
polycystic kidney disease and albert
syndrome but
as you can see here in this table we
really do have
a lot of different type but it really
does not matter which kind of disease
you have
ultimately the patients will end up with
the loss of kidney function
and they will need again dialysis
transplantation
so just to give you a little bit about
statistics in 2019
more than 112 000 people were waiting
for
uh organ donor and only um
thirty thousand uh forty thousand
transplants were uh
performed and you you can see here very
clearly the more than
twenty three thousand words for kidney
so
uh at this point uh you can really see
that
um you know it's it's
really relevant uh to um
to really find a new alternative
approach that can slow down
disease progression in this patient uh
in order to
understand and how to find a new
therapeutic approach we really need to
understand how the kidney works and in
particular
the infiltration unit of the kidney is
the nephron which is constituted by the
glomerulus and the tubules
you can see here the glomerulus uh where
the filtration occur and then you see
here the
proximal and distal tubule this is a
skinny electromicroscopy of the
glomerulus where the filtration
uh practically occurs so why do we have
chronic kidney disease
because uh no nephron can be regenerated
in adult life
we are born with a determined numbers on
nephron which
range from five hundred thousand to one
millions in human
and it doesn't if there is a damage
uh there is no possibility of uh nephron
uh to regenerate
um also uh chronic kidney disease
um mainly affected the as i said the
glomerulus but in particular the
glomerular filtration barrier
this is a very small but extremely
complex specialized structure
constituted only by two types of cells
one are the podocytes which are very
fascinating endothelial
epithelial cell
they present with processes as a lead
diaphragm
and they are extremely important to
occurs
uh importantly also these cells do not
replicate they are post methodic
cells then we do have the global
endothelials
also these are very particular
endothelial cells that you don't find in
any other part of our bodies
because they present a particular
fenestration they are the first step
for the filtration activity to occur
these two type of cells are separated by
a thin layer of glomerular base
membrane which is mainly constituted by
a trimer or collagen4
and in particular collagen four alpha
three four and five
which is present only here in the
glomerular filtration barrier and in the
inner ear
so it's a very particular type of
collagen
so the homostatic balance between the
glomerular cells and the glomerular
basal membrane
is absolutely necessarily evitable for
the filtration to occur
when there is an imbalance of signalling
normal
changing in this structure there is an
initiation and progression of chronic
kinesis
very importantly the treatment of ckd is
centering historically slowing down the
systemic uh the progression by systemic
approach like for example
uh down trying to regulate blood
pressure
and it does not exist a specific
therapeutic uh
therapeutic approach that actually
targets the glomerulus
so this is what we do in our laboratory
we are trying to
find a new approach to restore
practically garmental function
uh we in order to do this we really need
to better understand the technology
biology
and very importantly we need to
understand the molecular mechanisms that
determine the progression of the
glomerular disease
and this is important because not all
the glomeruli and tubules two
are actually affected in the same way
even within the same individual or
disease or tissue
and there are a lot of differences also
in gender
um between male and female even in a
healthy situation and not only in
chronic kidney disease
so here in this project we utilize the
uh
nanostring technology in particular the
digestive profiling and the human body's
crypto atlas where we identify more than
18
90 000 um mrnas
to really study the different glomerular
disease and how
the glomerular differ within the same
disease
and compared to other diseases we
studied albert syndrome first because
this
is a one a major focus in our laboratory
and then we compare
our results with other two type of
quite common uh glomerular disease which
is which are membranous nephropathy a
focused segmental sclerosis
so before showing uh you the results
i'll either give you
um i would give you a little bit details
of
about this disease because that is
important uh in order to understand
what are not our analysis revealed
so alport syndrome is a genetic disease
and affected the production of collagen
the collagen four alpha 3
4 and 5 that talked before and it's
very clear here in the electromicroscopy
that that thin layer of glomerular basal
membrane is actually
abnormal it's split and laminated and
the
patients that present this uh genetic
mutation
they have they present the protoneoria
glomerular sclerosis and
hearing loss and ocular manifestation
for the sites are lost within the urine
because they cannot properly attach
to their glomerular basal membrane and
the patient ultimately
might really need a transplant even in
early an early age
85 percent of the population present a
mutation on the collagen four alpha five
which is a excellent mutation the second
um chemises and particular glomerular
disease that we studied that we could
compare with alpha syndrome
is the membrane nephropathy in these
patients the
uh body produce antibodies against the
particular molecules that are
in the present in the surface of the
photocytes and in particular 80 percent
of the patients develop
antibodies and gastro they it's that is
called pl
plr 2r and
the when the antibody recognize that
antigen there is the formation of the
muno complex between
the podocytes and the glomerular meso
membrane
the patients present protoneoria like
caliper patients and then the third of
this
this patient there is a complete kidney
failure and you can see here from the
histology clearly that the glomeruli is
quite altered and there is also a
thing capillary of the walls and so
means that also the endothelial cells
are highly involved in the progression
of these diseases
finally the other common um
glomerular disease is a focal
supplemental glomerulous sclerosis and
as the name says there is a particular
formation of sclerosis plaque within the
glomerulus are very clear
here and um you can see
here the position of extracellular
metrics between podocytes and
endothelial cells
also these patients present the
proteinuria and present
a kidney failure also in early age
what is really particular about this
disease is that we really know what are
the clinical features we can do
astrological
uh partners and understand uh but but
we really don't know why really
happening
so um it's very clear for us that
applying uh
this um technology we will have
information
about different disease and we can
compare between them and we can actually
uh discover which are the mechanisms
that will regulate
the progression of disease in multiple
uh
in multiple diseases so for this project
we
um used uh our main focus which
are alpha biopsies in particular from
two patients a male and a female
this as you can see here uh based on
their age their
uh young their children and they have
the proteinuria and altered um
priatin then we use a focused
eclementary sclerosis
patients biopsies and in particular of a
male and female
which they have extremely high
proteinuria and then finally
are members on the property female with
a little bit of proteinuria
and as a control we used um
the healthy uh part of a kidney that was
extracted and underwent a nephropathy
and you can see here there is a
no no protein area
um at this point i will give this slide
that to
dr sedrake which will be who will be
telling you the results of our analysis
great thank you lara for that nice
introduction
uh going over the three different uh
disease types that we are analyzing and
so for the remainder of the presentation
i will give an overview of the
preliminary results we obtained from our
whole transcriptome analysis and so
uh as highlighted by the definitions and
descriptions of the three different
pathologies glomerulus uh was really the
center of our attention
as the disease was really is really
important uh
uh glomerulus is really the target uh
for these three different pathologists
and generally speaking in in chronic
kidney disease
glomerulus is really targeted in 80 of
the cases
and so uh our first attention was to
look at the glomeruli
and here's a representative histology
images of the
regions of interest the glomeruli that
we very meticulously and carefully
selected to rule out any uh
contamination from the tubules
and we use some morphology markers to uh
to be able to
identify a potentially more uh
fibrotic versus less vibrating glomeruli
so we that
can compare uh differences within
within within the same disease and also
across
different different pathologies that we
have
so we had very clear-cut isolation
of the glomeruli but we didn't stop
there we also
are interested in the tubulin even
though glomerulus is the target
eventually as the disease progresses the
tubules are affected as well
and unlike the glomeruli which is uh
relatively uh homogeneous in terms of
the cell composition
and function triple are a little bit
more diverse
along the nephron there are different
tubular cells
that perform different function and so
we uh
very specifically identified the two
different main kinds
the distal and proximal tubules and we
selected uh samples from both
to understand the differences and so
these are representative images again
using the same morphology markers
and so uh very quickly on the on the
data processing
the libraries were sequenced uh on a
nextgen 2000
platform yielding uh roughly about 500
million features we used the paradigm
assay
using a third unique molecular
identifier primers
that provides uh very high accuracy and
confidence in our
readouts and for normalization q3 method
was applied
to remove any non-biological radiation
within the sample
and since we're used we were using uh
you know human biopsy samples that were
stored in the repository coming from
all the way from europe it was important
to perform some
quality check assays and
it was very encouraging to see that we
had a very good uh
sequencing data shown by the graph in
the left
with a sequencing saturation of roughly
around
90 percent across all the samples
yielding
high confidence counts across across the
different uh
regions and different samples that's
shown in the violin plots
in the right and then we performed
this other quality
assay that is the signal-to-noise ratio
and what we are seeing in this heat map
is
a very strong you know very strong
signal
in in in all the samples across the
across the different pathologies and of
course all the
regions of interest with a very nice
dynamic range
that is very promising which means we
would be able to
get some very interesting uh
observations
so the first thing we were really
interested at looking
since we identified and isolated two
different structures
tubules and glomeruli to really see if
the
you know the differential gene
expression really distinguishes between
the two
and uh interestingly enough
i highlighted some of the genes that
popped out in this comparison plot
between the gloms and tubules really
projecting the uh the the typical
markers of glomerular cells namely the
podocytes
shown here by the uh expression of
nephilim cardosine
and photocalyxin for the endothelial
cells we had the ehd3
uh that's a very nice cellular marker
and the uh for endothelial cells and
from essential cells we we're seeing the
pdgf
receptor beta that's highly uh
highly present in the glomeruli versus
tubules so this is very encouraging
really showing that uh we are able to
identify
them by the expression of this unique
markers
then to really the digest
some of this complex data we performed
some dimensional reduction
and uh in this principle component
analysis we're looking
uh at the different uh
at the different diseases uh all
combined uh
mainly the output the fsgs and
membranous nephropathy
relative to normal and i hope you can
appreciate that
in this in this plot we we we have a
very clear separation between the globes
shown in circles and the tubules
depicted with the squares on the
upper quadrants so there's a clear
distinguishing
distinct separation between the gloms
and tubules
which is very nice and confirms the the
violin platform the previous slide
but also we see a very nice separation
between the
glomeruli and tubules
across diseased and normal samples are
shown by the color-coded
designations and of course
there might be some differences across
different
diseases between the gloms and tubules
but this projection doesn't really show
so uh i will show additional pca
projections later that
provide some some additional insight
into the possible
variations between them so the next
pca analysis is actually looking at the
f
at the uh at the females and the males
of the alport
samples showing a clear separation here
again between the glomeruli and tubules
with the circles and the squares and
possibly some differentiation also
between the males and females that would
be very interesting to understand
as well so tubals and glomeruli are
different
and also the diseased and healthy are
are
separating very nicely and this is very
encouraging
for for further analysis that we'll be
uh doing
later on to understand some of the
mechanisms and then pathways that
laura mentioned that we're interested in
uh in the next slide here i have uh
only gloms so because in outport for
example
the glomeruli is very important because
of the mutation of the collagen
that laura talked about uh everything
really starts here
and it was very important for us to to
look into the
the glomeruli specifically between the
different genders and understand the
difference in the
in the molecular mechanisms it's because
we know from the
from the patients that the the
progression of the disease is really
really uh
different in the males and females and
also there's
there's definitely a variation in terms
of the mutations
uh that occur uh namely the different
alpha primers but it's interesting to
see that we have
we have some some separation between the
males and
and the females here of course the
samples are not
um may not be very clearly matched in
terms of
the the stage of the disease or maybe
also
the age but we should be able to just
sit for some
uh some information that will be very
useful uh
now as we you know uh move forward with
uh
our understanding of these different
pathologies
we were able to look at some
differential gene expression
and again i should mention that this is
still very preliminary
but as we compare the glomeruli
in outport versus healthy we can see
that
there's a large number of sets large set
of genes that are
definitely down regulated and they seem
to be
indicating some early developmental
markers
that are important during development
that might have been upregulating
outward
and more specifically looking at the
differences between the males and
females in the two
volcano plants on the right we
identified
some interesting markers that might be
of uh very
uh uh important to look in the future
namely the lrp11 which is a
low-density lipoprotein
receptor-associated protein
and and as indicated to be involved
in um lipid metabolism
and also the interleukin-411
known to have a role in uh even though
you know it's a it's an
immunosuppressive enzyme
uh that has a role you know you know
immunosuppressive processes
so these two uh markers are
interestingly operating between the
in the male outport uh glomeruli but not
in the female
and i'm going to emphasize this uh here
as this two enzymes uh two markers
really show up later on in the fsgs and
the memories without the sample so there
might be some commonality between
between them in terms of these pathways
that is interesting
in addition to the differences we see
some similarities in terms of the hux e4
hux b8 sorry expression between the
males and females so we need to
really understand uh how this some this
this markers
uh add up uh we will need to perform um
gene enrichment and pathway engagement
analysis obviously to discover some of
the mechanisms
then uh here we're looking at uh
another volcano plot between the male
and female glomeruli
showing really the distinction between
the two there are definitely some
markers that are
worth investigating so uh despite the
similarities
uh in terms of mutations uh
the ecology really uh drives some
molecular like
mechanisms and vice versa that is worth
investigating
and important also for development of
therapies obviously
so moving forward
this analysis here is a comparison
between
focal segmental glomeruloscosis and
membranes nephropathy in term in
relative
terms to the normal we're looking at the
glomeruli
and i hope you can appreciate the in
this projection the clear separation
between
all the different regions and
groups in this analysis namely the
separation between
fsgs the males and females shown by the
pink and the green circles
on the top in the top quadrants
separation between the
fsgs and membranous nephropathy that is
the
the yellow portion in the center
as well as between all the diseased
color circles
and and the healthy glomeruli so
we are confident that we have a very
very interesting data to look at in
terms of
understanding uh some of the details
so looking at the differential gene
expression for the focal segmental
glomerular sclerosis again
as i mentioned two interesting markers
uh
lrp11 and looking for
are popping up they are highly elevated
in both the male and female
so we think there is some commonality
between
between these two uh uh diseases uh
alport and fsgs and also in the mn that
i'll show later
uh very interesting again
in terms of down regulation of a lot of
a lot of markers that we see on the left
side of the plot
indicating some
mechanisms that are are down regulated
uh in this uh volcano plaid now we're
looking at membranes nephropathy
and i want to again point out
interleukin-41a
that seems to be elevated again
emphasizing
some commonality we also have a lot of
genes that are popping up on the left
side specifically april l3
that is known to be involved in the in
the proto-site
in ckd so
overall we have a very nice presentation
of genes and markers
that will give us a definitely very
interesting insight as we move forward
we were also fortunate that in addition
to the wtw
uh whole genome uh transcriptome uh
analysis
we could perform some protein uh
protein assay nanostring has provided
this opportunity to look at some of the
proteins
using the same roi that we had on the on
the same
samples on the same diseases and
using a panel of 59 proteins from the
immune
activation immune cell you know
profiling panel
immune cell typing and immune and
oncology drug targets myeloid panel and
tumor panel we we looked at some of
these proteins
that will eventually confirm
our findings from the whole
transcriptome so this is very uh very
interesting
uh to look at we still are waiting for
you know complete analysis but we have
some preliminary information
um that uh shows a very good um
you know noise um signal-to-noise ratio
indicating that the proteins were
detectable and we should be able to
uh analyze this and uh
and and compare to our transcriptomic
data
this will lead uh lead to interesting
findings
of course in understanding potential
mechanisms of actions that's like
cellular and molecular level so
to wrap up i would like to conclude by
saying that
we observed the differences between all
three
renal pathologies alport fsgs and
membranous nephropathy
in the glomeruli specifically as well as
between the glomeruli and tubules within
each disease
we know that not all glomerular tubules
are affected in the same way
as was previous previously mentioned
even within the same kidney
and spatial profiling can really clearly
help us understand
uh some of these differences in a very
spectacular and special way
we know that males and females are often
affected with ckd differently
and this was clearly observed in our
output and fsgs samples
and we hope to be able to do the same
also for the membranes nephropathy as
move forward
and understanding their differences at
transcriptional level could really lead
out to more specific and and targeted
personalized therapies
in the future and ultimately special
profiling
of gene expression and hopefully also
you know protein expression would be a
powerful tool that would allow us to
answer some of the very important
questions about the mechanisms of
disease progression
in outport fhgs and membranous
nephropathy
and we hope that we can also look into
some other
pathologies as well especially diabetic
nephropathy is a huge
and many people are affected by it
and lastly i would like to thank our
group
for uh for
for you know studies in the kidney and
we have
we have a long track record looking into
the outport and
other renal pathologists and special
thanks to paulo cravetti for
providing the human biopsy samples for
this analysis
and of course all the funding and
management for uh
for this work thank you
oh that was wonderful uh thank you laura
and sergius that was a great
presentation
so i have just a few questions here um
i'll uh
maybe start with with laura um so some
questions on the roi
uh selection um how did you approach the
roi selection
um and how are you able to focus your
key questions
on the specific structures
so um we look at the slides before
and um we are i think a very lucky in
the kidney field
because we can really distinguish the
structures of the glomerulus versus the
uh
tubals so we could really logically
uh mark around the um capsule the arena
capsule for
uh in relation to the glomeruli so we
could
really detect the um the filtration
barrier
and then also from the glomeruli it was
it was easy to
uh determine the uh differences between
the interstitial space
and um sorry for the tubals it was easy
to determine the difference between the
intestinal space
and the glomer um it was a little bit
difficult to distinguish between the
proximally the tubals
the proximal and the distal tubers
especially in the disease
because they are damaged so
in that case hopefully the spatial
respiratory economics
the spatial would tell us some molecular
that will help us in the future to
distinguish between these two type
of tubals
that's great
and and to follow on um you know what
that question
what steps would you take to better
understand
these results and translate it into the
broader population
i think that's a very interesting
question and very important question
in fact that's what we are asking
ourselves
in fact as we're looking at this data
and and the answer is the following we
definitely need to
uh look into more samples uh
from this three different etiologies and
obviously
if opportunity heats so we would like to
also investigate uh
other forms of chronic kidney disease uh
namely diabetic nephropathy would be
very interesting
and the more samples we are able to run
i think we will be able to get
more robust and sound uh
confirmation of our understanding of the
molecular mechanisms
that will give us a pretty uh
confident uh you know information
for moving forward in terms of
designing new therapies and targeted
therapies
to treat kidney disease yeah
that's great to hear um thank you both
um we are thrilled to be working with
you um on this
exciting project yep um and we're
excited to see what's gonna happen next
um so thanks again um this
concludes the speech you're welcome
uh this concludes the spatial biology
track um i would
again like to thank all of our speakers
uh for their talks
um as a final reminder we will follow up
any questions that you may have asked in
the chat
via email and we now have a break before
the spatial genomics data analysis track
uh please join our live geomex
interactive data experience
happening uh now during the break and
please visit the exhibit hall
the virtual lab and the poster sessions
to gain points
and learn more about spatial biology
thank you again for your participation
in the conference and joining us for
these presentations
thank you thanks